[Music]
welcome back to hot seat the show with
the hottest evening and then even hotter
questions and today we have anthony lee
he is a man who dances for money
what are you getting
he's a dancer and to start it off with a
very very very cold questions
let's go with bar
are you a fan of
clothes pins
clothespins as usual we're driving
engagement with this first one
that seems like a very bit of a
sensitive subject you know okay could be
i do uh kind of enjoy clothespins i
think that they're they're fun i think
when i was a kid i really liked putting
them on my fingers
and just having like long like wolverine
like fingers but other than that i don't
know did you ever put on your penis
no where are the foreskin
no how about you pretend to pierce your
ears and through put it through your
ears i think i probably put it on my
ears before yeah that sounds like
something i'll probably all right all
over i think this is still a really cool
one
what about have you ever seen your
sister naked
that's a good question it's that one
minute mark where we turn it up
taking a page out of steve green
if you haven't seen your sister naked
it's kind of weird because you grew up
with her so it's kind of actually odd so
you guys thanks steve they're talking
about the growing up years
have you ever seen our naked and how did
you feel about it as an adult no just
any time you could be three four seven
oh it doesn't have to be jesus most
memorable moments 33
whatever
yeah yeah top five
this isn't even a weird question i don't
get why we've been asked this question
it's not even that way as a child
i've seen my sister naked wow kind of
controversial how did you feel about it
i was a child i don't think i had i
think it was like cooties
were you like oh cool sister you're so
naked i'm naked too or were you like no
yeah that's yucky why is my sister naked
next to me
probably that one
you want a third you need a third off
well i'm down for the next question mark
give him a third and the third option
the third option
do you like scrambled eggs or overeating
that's an option
it's just a whole other thing oh man i
like making scrambled eggs because it's
just so fun to [ __ ] scramble stuff
yeah but i enjoy eating over easy more
often though soft scramble according to
the fbi
eating scrambled eggs is uh has to do
with channel poor donkey oh my god
especially first thing your answer right
now
what got you into what got you into
dance
dance ooh uh cliche but real answer
people like michael jackson uh king of
pop just seeing him do his thing trying
to emulate that king of kids and king of
pop that's right at the time
at the time it was just pop nah he's my
favorite too
was there a move that he did that was
really good sir that's he's the goat for
that this reason
uh
i mean both the smooth criminal lien and
his moonwalk were obviously like i think
just the most iconically fun for me but
i could never do the lean because i
didn't know how to do it until i grew up
and i had to youtube and research it
nick's i'm about to show you right now
oh yeah so nick's getting in the stance
what people don't know is that he was
actually wearing shoes that were very
very very heavy
michael jackson made it lugs lugs he's
working
i remember though patton did it annually
michael michael jackson made it
normalized to fondle myself in public
you can't do it without the noise though
you'll get in trouble you gotta do with
the noise kick too yes my question to
you nick dunn how many dance battles
have you won in
in your career
like a formal event or like a no camera
is just like a moment impromptu
formal
with the scores table everything uh i
never really entered battles i was not
really a battler i didn't enter like a
battle one time it didn't make it past
prelims uh that was fun
uh and then uh we do a lot of in-house
battles and kinders and stuff like that
aka people before you get to that how
does lose what's the what's losing a
battle behavior like
like someone does a move and then and
then you get shut down i didn't [ __ ]
get into well for again for me battles i
like lost at prelims so uh yes when they
beat you do you what like you go oh man
or like what is it
yes you're pretty disappointed
is this like ice skating where you like
land a triple axel but then you like
wobbled a little bit and then
immediately like yeah and you already
know or is it more like drumline where
you or you drum on the guy's drums and
then that's like the ultimate sign of
disrespect the sticks owns you [ __ ] you
yeah you know yeah that actually is more
my f uh
my favorite type of moment see i bet
okay i i know you anthony lee yeah
that's why i asked you this question
it's like i colonized that guy's drum
yeah
so what's mine now tell us about a time
that you won a battle that what was the
matter and what's your finishing move
yeah they vote
again i'm not really a battler oh count
it like competitions that you you've
been the director of these like teams
too because that's also the same
wow thank you ryan
directing choreographic teams and
winning a competition is
slightly different though right because
most people will think about battling
like like [ __ ] you got service
something like one on one or fight style
competition right which is a little more
impromptu because maybe you don't know
what song is going what song's about to
drop or whatever whereas like
choreographic competitions you're like
working on a three-month show and
putting together the set yourself and
kind of like
strategically being like what maybe
other teams might do and how can we beat
them so it's very very different um but
what's your question i got one once
money gets involved with
with dance and stuff because it gets
your passion you love it and you've told
you've talked to me about this before
actually privately uh where it's like it
was it's it's almost like the joker
movie where you like
you you've described it to me like that
where dance can take you to a different
place and just help relax you yeah but
what happens when you incorporate money
with it is it like
okay now i have to work and this is kind
of different does it [ __ ] it up for you
i think it's like all like a a nice ride
and i feel like i'm at like this part of
the ride because in the beginning when
you start getting like financial
opportunity to do your passion you're
also [ __ ] stoked like oh my god
somebody's paying me for doing something
i love right and then like however long
that might last for you and you're like
how much you love it or your career or
the types of jobs you do
like i feel like once you get the wisdom
of experience wisdom usually comes also
from the pain of experience so like i
remember [ __ ] i was in china and i
had to do a kfc spot and they dressed me
up like a crawfish because they were
doing a new crawfish burger bro i
thought they were going to dress up like
a chicken i thought so too but actually
i didn't want to dress like an animal i
just thought i was going to dance and
promote it kfc has crawfish in china
they were doing like a seasonal promo
where they're putting [ __ ] crawfish
into their chicken sandwiches wow and
then i didn't again there's a lot of
language barriers so i didn't know that
i had to dress up like a crawfish
and there was this moment where i was
arguing with the director because like
you know i was egotistical at the time
too just everything that i had done in
china and i was like what the [ __ ] i'm
not going to dress up as a crawfish but
that was the entire negotiation that i
wasn't a part of
were they like it's a balenciaga
crawfish
ah man
it's designed by balenciaga
supreme logo
yeah that's very china but but yeah so
like moments like that are the ones that
you're like [ __ ] like what am i doing
i'm like doing steps wearing a giant
[ __ ] so you ended up doing it you had
to that's so funny
do you have footage of that
unfortunately somebody does yeah
all right so we also know you as a sex
hobby right huge success
notorious what's what's your most
confident move yeah that's a good
question what's your finisher dude
yeah while he's having sex or to attain
uh
while you're having sex what's your
what's the move that at least a hundred
people have experienced before
at least
especially
what keeps them coming back
what's your most what's your most
confident move there what makes a return
customer yeah
there's so many the whole experience i
think so many ways
i will say
i will say
my
willingness
to
go down on the chick
such a sex harvard dude you're a modern
man yeah he's a giver man
sex giver that's his new name not sex
haver sex he's a sex giver can we talk
technique for a sec just between dudes
yeah it's all dudes you're all chill
yeah oh god do you just go in there and
[ __ ] start bombing that [ __ ] with your
tongue
yeah do you warm it up
what are you how do you define bombing a
[ __ ] though right now
i use the most powerful [ __ ] advanced
weaponry that my tongue has
i turned the [ __ ] immediately and just
carved on that [ __ ] non-stop
damn you're trying to be like attack
guns
no chance i was just like
how many what's the duration of you
doing that however long it takes until
unconditional surrender
[Laughter]
that is the most important thing though
once once you start you know what i mean
and then they've already gotten their
orgasms on their multiple yeah
everything else comes like easily you
know what i mean versus like i remember
sex ever sex happened you guys
good tips i just remember earlier in my
years when i was satisfied customers
when i was not billions i said stop it
when i wasn't thinking about giving as
much and but i was like hoping to
receive you know what i'm saying
everybody's always hoping to receive
figures
yeah and then my mind i'm like hopefully
gonna blow me
[Laughter]
oh my god oh blowie would just really
make my week
but but it's it's when you give first
then afterwards it's like okay
today's video is brought to you by
ferrity all right you know what's going
on right now everyone's talking about
this
fake spring like it's so hard i don't
know what to dress what do i get what
especially like like guys are always
getting slammed for their fashion
they're just like man
put on some good clothes yeah and fake
spring is supposed to be fake because it
feels like it's gonna be cold but it
gets hot all of a sudden it gets cold
all of a sudden so where can i go to get
some clothes where it feels good for all
seasons luckily ferrari makes it way
easier look at this high quality ass
shirt did you know their stuff is
lifetime guarantee
so you can wear it down to the holes and
then they'll give you another one no
questions asked ferriti is a family-run
brand making super high quality timeless
clothing with modern design and
functionality it's that kind of
effortless style you want every time
every time you go digging in your closet
that set that shirt that dress that
feels like you had it for years look at
this maybe it's in a gorgeous print and
it looks like it might be vintage yep
but it fits so well that it feels like
it was my yesterday man and then the
quality is good it's really good
actually just made just for you well
that's parody man i like how this one i
had to keep the tags on to show you guys
a fresh new pair
i'm actually already wearing a t-shirt
right here is this the stretch materials
yeah so this is the cool thing it it
looks just like super casual right yeah
but man you know i'm gonna swim with
these in hawaii yeah you know i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna be everywhere with
these and that's all i do anyway is i
wear shorts like 10 months out of the
year yeah
so this i'm excited for this one you
know
i really like high quality t-shirts but
then usually um when they're too thick i
feel like hot and sweaty and i don't
like it and you know summer's right
around the corner but this one it's
smooth and it i feel like it keeps me a
little cool head to ferritybrand.com off
the record and use code off the record
at checkout to snag 20
off all your new spring staples that's
code off the record at faraday
f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand.com off the record for 20 off
veritybrand.com off the record that's
true because if you use like the battle
dancing analogy like from dance to
dancer
so like
when someone's challenging you
you can't refuse like when someone walks
up and then they do the whole like that
you gotta you gotta [ __ ] you gotta
you
that's the thing dude like so it's the
same strategy in sex like if she's there
you're [ __ ] doing the tango and you
got to be like it's battle time baby and
you
say it's a community center yeah
you got to keep it open
10 59.
so we gotta make it serious the part of
the show we make it serious what's
your what's the theme that is the most
frightening or that you're the most
scared of
in life yeah do you have like the worst
case scenario moment that you're like
okay i'm gonna do all it takes to
prevent this from happening
i think i'm i think i'm uh afraid to be
alone
like like not alone for a moment you
know what i mean um but like like
if all my loved ones passed away and i
was like left straight [ __ ]
like uh
your fiance
parents just all relate like all
relatives yeah yeah every anybody who's
gonna get the my closest like i think
that fear of being alone and like
i think that's probably the scariest
part for me that's [ __ ] true
like including like let's say
because me and my relatives aren't the
best so if they're all god i'm like i
got friends and stuff too uh i was like
with my situation i love my friends more
than my family
your inner circle is not necessarily
blood but just your inner circle my song
like yeah yeah george zakawa yeah me
dancing
um do you consider yourself like an
extrovert then or an introvert or like
we talked about this here i forgot
positive extrovert
what does that mean i don't really know
but uh
but i love i'm like a homebody i love
staying in i love when people come to me
because sometimes me going out to people
like for some reason that drains my
energy
i love recharging on my own but
obviously i love also being in company
so it
when i when i tell my friend was people
was like you're an extrovert if i ever
even joke around and be like i don't
know if i'm an extrovert people start
like yelling you're a [ __ ] extrovert
it gets really crazy yeah but by that
definition you're actually an introvert
if you recharge alone
that's an introvert because it's just
depending on how you get energy what is
it both i have a bachelor's in
psychology so don't [ __ ] with me
bachelor's bro dude
[ __ ] bachelor doctor judge it's a
coward
i could do both i could i could uh it's
not about me who cares um
[Laughter]
so
my next question for you actual question
for you um so nina your chick
yes she's she's really cool i love nina
she's awesome i'm still scared if you
had to if you could change anything
about nina what would you change your
mind you can't change the fact she's
filipino so yeah nice try no race no
race changing [ __ ]
i know you would want to and don't say
you wish she was 17 either yeah
thank you bart nobody nobody said i know
what anthony was going but don't say
that
it doesn't leave you with a whole lot
[Laughter]
you guys are [ __ ]
this might be the best hot seat ever
physically has to be about her
personality no anything just life
situation
except her nose or something it could be
something she says about herself that
she's like i wish i could change this
could be anything you wish she had less
split ends or something you know i wish
she like
loved cooking
no
she cooks and she fits well yeah and i
love her cooking but if she loved it you
know you know like because i've also
like lived with a chef chef rob you
remember
right and it like it's just like yeah
you get spoiled it's just like
somebody's just trying to like oh i
thought about this flavor starts [ __ ]
making [ __ ] hey you want to try this
but it's like whoa if i had somebody
like
do you do you love cooking no then why
do you expect that out of her
oh
hello doctor tell them doc
that's what partners do so
that's true so you want her to cook more
frequently or like you wish you could
cook more frequently no no i want her to
love it so that even if she whether she
does it it's just enjoyable versus
thinking that it's like a chore yeah or
something
or something
because my cooking sucks even though i
enjoy
trying
uh i'm really good at ordering food
what's the best meal you can cook what's
best for me like an order is better i
don't know the best meal you can cook
yeah what's your favorite
and everything eggs related like devil
eggs no no no easiest thing to do
scrambled eggs over easy eggs sunny side
up eggs that's it just eggs
how about this one we always ask
everyone here um
but your biggest regret
give us something we can really pry on
and use for ammunition later yeah yeah
and remember like you
and just to give you a little hint
earlier you talked about having to close
a business so you could maybe you could
just talk about that if you want and how
much that hurt your pride emotions
think about how hard that was how much
made you [ __ ] cry
i think i rushed into certain things
about business too quickly before being
knowledgeable enough oh you sensible son
of a [ __ ]
how so what did you do nice and so good
it's like as basic as like if you don't
know uh
llc formations and then you like uh
start a business in the wrong type of
tax code you know what i mean and then
you get [ __ ] later in ways that you
don't and you're just constantly
backtracking and like uh
you got like holes all over your sinking
ship and you're trying to plug holes
versus like if you would have just built
a good boat to start and it doesn't have
to be a [ __ ] yacht or perfect ship
you just needed to have some knowledge
you know what i mean true so if you
could tell your younger self because i'm
pretty sure someone's watching and going
man
i could do a kenji studio myself i could
[ __ ] make noodles myself anthony's my
inspiration what would you tell
that dude out there who's trying to
[ __ ] compete right now how not to
make the same mistakes i could make a
shoe
yeah i could make a nike shoe i also
think i tried to do too many things at
once
i think if i just focus on a studio only
then any of the holes or the problems
that might come with it i could probably
fix it and focus on it what got you to
get so excited about doing 20 things at
once
because i think that's what's exciting
doing things not necessarily doing
anything
you know what i mean like even for me
like dance isn't my thing dances i
always talk about how dance is like my
vehicle it's not the place that i want
to be it's the thing that takes me
places
so like the joy of being like oh maybe i
could do this and trying is more fun
than like doing one thing to me you know
what i'm saying even though i understand
that doing one thing and be [ __ ] good
at it is also a whole different
adventure you know is there a fear in
that like honest question like it's like
i want to do a bunch of things so that
like i can put my fingers in as many
pies as possible so that if anything
goes down i'm secure enough like is
there is it is it through a fear thing
or is it through an excitement thing or
is it both
i think it's a curiosity thing for me
okay because i don't think there was a
point where i was like i want to do all
these things i think it was more like
you get to a spot and suddenly like oh
this door could open
i want to walk through this door yeah
and not really think about the next
three or four doors as if i had some
sort of [ __ ] master plan as far as
just in dance
do you feel like you've accomplished
everything you dreamt of doing just
dancer to grappler just wanna know
i think when i was younger and i i
dreamt of things that i was like this
would be like my finished accomplishment
right like for example i probably dreamt
of like uh
directing a theater show oh and i
haven't done that but i didn't dream of
like working with nike to make a shoe
right you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
i feel i feel holistically accomplished
enough to be like oh i i feel good but
it doesn't mean i did everything that i
felt like i had a checkbox for
going back to the the question with nina
but flipping it
is there a part of you this is serious
is there a part of you you wished you
could change that would be better for
nina and what would that be
say cooking
you wish you loved cooking
it's the same exact thing i do wish i
was a [ __ ] good cook yeah like if i
was [ __ ] good if anybody could do it
yeah but but to be more fun um either
like a huge penis don't say 17 either um
i wish i was 17 for her
i just saw that answer from his mouth
he's about to say it yeah i saw it too
maybe if i was less of a gemini i feel
like the [ __ ] does that mean
i feel like my gemini nature is dancing
like i'm like kind of like uh hot and
cold sometimes switching signs like a
gemini
i think if i was like a little bit more
consistent for her aquarius ass you know
what i'm saying like it would be easier
but at the same time that's maybe what
makes me exciting what is
gemini like hot coal what do you mean
stereotypically i feel like it's like
the uh the two-faced constellations like
broken promises it's like being
generally broken
it's like being a genderfluid it's like
the same thing oh
exactly i'm gender fluid
i also in gemini that's why would you
say cause like
i mean you've told me before that it's a
gentleman i could make that you know
there are people watching you all the
time and you don't necessarily know who
they are and then like you have to kind
of put like this brand out there and
like you as well
like would you say you've touched a lot
of kids
no why is that funny it's not funny yeah
you're right it's not funny
sorry anthony because you do have a lot
of followers
no
no i haven't touched you
your content never made an impact
that's interesting you have so many kids
looking up at you i think you're being
too self-critical man i think you have
touched a lot of kids you're like a lot
you don't hate this you feel like you
never you never made an impact with all
of your content that you touched anybody
i think you've touched millions of kids
think about it
there's much kids down here and you're
sitting right up here i know right like
they're
in a way you're touching them
i think it's beautiful but you're
running away from it yeah
i think you hit them all in their
special place i would even say privately
i am constantly trying to positively
impact people through my art politician
look at that
how do you define people as is uh
17 years and 11 months people still or
not
or that is that's not because bart
started it
i was just randomly a trending joke
runner i wasn't i wasn't in control this
is a new format for hot seat once he
made it to runner i was like fine that's
the runner
this is the first hot seat where he's
actually sweating like it's hot
it's hot
this is the hottest hot seat dude
[Music]
you